everyone I'm gonna tell you about last
semester that's going to happen in the
spring some of these slides I used
actually last year but there's some new
ones and I'm organizing this with Daniel
Emma chancho from UCSD from which we
know by Connecticut from MIT and how
thick we who's your Paris normally but
no he's also an Algren Boston a so
Madison so this is a picture of the
lattice points essentially according to
a basis so these are two basis vectors
and you can express all combinations
with integer lattices of the N basis
vectors turns out that for this same
lattice you could have different bases
we have a notion of a short basis a long
basis a better basis or worse basis the
points it's combinations of these bases
so in fact there are infinitely many
bases that are possible and there are
some computational problems that we can
define with respect to this structure
and have been defined for its note it
doesn't come really from our woods but
this is well known mathematical problems
so for example one problems is the
shortest vector problem so given a basis
so given these vectors b1 and b2 or up
to BN find shortest nonzero vector so a
combination of them that will give us a
shortest vector it turns out that this
problem will vary in difficulty
depending on what basis we are given so
some basis is are gonna allow to find
such a short vector much more
efficiently than others so a first step
in some sense you could think of for
solving this problem is to find such
better basis
[Music]
another problem is called the closest
vector problem and that is again we are
given a basis to specify the lattice and
the kind of question we're asking now is
not the shortest vector that is in the
lattice as a combination integer
combination of these basis vectors but
given a point that's not one of the
green points find the closest point
which is green to it so that's the
closest it's not in the Landis and we
would like to know something I think the
green one is close to it that's another
one of these hard problems what do I
mean by hard I mean that we don't have
polynomial time algorithms for it
in fact we don't even have good
polynomial time algorithms to
approximate the answer so we have the
notion of alpha approximation for
shortest vector again given the basis
fine and alpha approximate shortest
nonzero so the difference you know as an
alpha factor away we can do the same for
the closest vector okay so this is a
problem that's extremely important for
computer science so well the best
example what this would give us is
integer programming so it did you
program me you know this is something
that's very familiar we've got a bunch
of equations we want to have a solution
what an integer solution so whereas if
this we didn't insist on integer
solutions we can do this simplex might
not be polynomial time worst case but we
have formal time algorithms integer so
the solutions that's np-hard and however
we can also think of this is a lattice
problem so we can think of a lattice and
find a solution would be the point in
this lattice inside of this convex body
and that we do in in turn that means
that for given a basis for this lattice
we can think of it as finding a shorter
closed vector in the corresponding
lattice and again if we had a good basis
it's become an easier problem so a lot
of pictures here just to give you an
idea that this structure this
mathematical structure has direct
correlation to solving some the most
basic problems that we can think about
in optimization and indeed
this is probably one of the most famous
algorithms if not the most famous
algorithm when I was a graduate student
or maybe I was a system professor
already so Leinster then syllabus
algorithm the lq finds the shortest
vector in constant dimension see
polynomial time and to the n over two
approximation in n dimensions so this is
a polynomial time that's a good news
it's only an approximation unless you
restrict the dimensions okay so what we
want to do in this semester is so the
corollary is the integer programming is
in constant um of variables it's
solvable in polynomial time anyway
[Music]
the best algorithm for when we don't
restrict but we allow it to grow if
alpha approximation runs in this here it
will give me an alpha factor of
approximation but the running time is
exponential so all this is not great
news in terms of running time but but it
is interesting that it's even true for
quantum algorithms whereas you know a
lot of famous problems number theory you
know factoring discrete log and so forth
elliptic curve log can be done very
quickly on a quantum computer we have no
idea how to beat this really on a
quantum computer and all this is good
for cryptography so especially we're
looking for hard problems and it used to
be that the factoring squeek law of
elliptic log where they're hard problems
on which whole electronic commerce is
based on I think or Mila also we'll talk
about this in a minute what she talks
about her program which isn't about at
the same time but in any case we want to
have something that's easy on one hand
when you are the legal user in the
system let's say you're their sender and
the receiver but it's hard for an
adversary trying to break a crypto
system the crypto system might be
encryption might be digital signatures
might be a cryptographic protocols we're
not restricting to one thing in
particular and lattices obviously since
there's a hard problem we would like to
have a structure there where there's
something that's easy and something
that's hard and in fact that is the case
a again just to iterate the reason why
this is great for cryptography it's
because the best algorithms
exponentially hard it is quantum
resistant there is this incredible
theorem or field it talks about that
it's not just hard on the average but
it's hard in the worst case in fact this
whole attention to lattice base
photography was by a theorem by I type
totally motivated by a theoretical basic
research type of interest finding a
problem which seems to be hard in the
worst case and you showed a reduction
between worst case and average and for
cryptography that's really what you want
because we're going to use sort of
average instances in real life and we
want to have some evidence that those
are average case instances are hard is
the reduction between that in the worst
case interesting thing is that not only
that we have a problem here that it's
hard but it really and that we are able
to kind of identify some easy
counterpart to the hard part but it
actually has much more ability much more
structure in it enables a lot of
surprising capabilities which we don't
even know how to do for cryptography
based on numbers here so the first
public key
this picture here I tie who did the
worst case the average and the first
cryptosystem that's really based on
lattices was a by I tie and work a
public-key cryptosystem so there was
number theory based like RSA then there
was based on lattices and then it turned
out that not only that you can do
encryption but you could do homomorphic
encryption with lettuces and what
morphic encryption people probably heard
about this term the idea is a super
duper kind of encryption where not only
that you can encrypt public key settings
so I can encrypt to to look her and he
can decrypt and he I've never met him
before but he published a public key but
furthermore so this is classical
encryption right now we want to actually
let's say have like a genomic database
that's just an application there's lots
of encrypted genetic data by many
different people and you would like to
do it G was let's say a genome acquired
Association study but without decrypting
first can you do it can you compute
unencrypted data without decrypting and
with homomorphic encryption allows you
to do such computation so that's saying
that G was example you could do gos
analysis unencrypted genomic sequences
with encryption based on lattices we
don't know how to do this based on
number theory and sort of secure
collaboration say so this is all
beautiful people have known this since
2008 because there's this system that
Agentry when he was a graduate student
and Stanford came up with homomorphic
encryption based on some baddest
problems now it progressed tremendously
since 2008 so when Gentry came out with
it he wasn't exactly the lattice problem
it was some variant of it on your ID
lattices now we know that we can
actually use like approximation of
shortest vector problem is a basis for
the homomorphic encryption schemes that
exist today that's one and two it was
sort of hailed as the most infeasible
theoretical result out there that's
never nobody's ever going to be able to
use it and so forth and you know I hate
to hear these kind of statements because
it's never right you know it's just a
question of effort in time in my
experience and indeed for example
you just clear from what I said you send
all your encryption over somebody
compute since you make the result so in
fact these days there is this
competition for example that happens in
UC San Diego it's called the I -
competition every year they have a
different challenge on genomic data how
to use cryptographic machinery to
analyze genomic data and the last one
was to actually use homomorphic
encryption in the past he was to use
multi-party protocols but little by
little they're getting to the heart
challenge which is using homomorphic
encryption so something you couldn't
think of doing in 2008 this year you
know they had like 300 patients they'd
uh 10,000 snips whatever this means from
genomic data and the question is to do
an analysis that's it I'm out of time
well okay and in fact in the effective
running times are amazing I mean you
could do things like you know these are
second okay so I just want to say in my
one minute that I stole from the program
that it's not just a homomorphic
encryption but for example this morning
I think it was Jerry Lee they talked
about this result from Microsoft about
that under RSA there's some difficulty
or actually not difficulty over bus
classification so there's a new result
by you know tin oxide that they show
assuming the harness of learning parity
with noise which is related to this lot
of stuff but not exactly lattice but
related to it they show that there's a
classification task which these three
things could exist there is easily
learned efficient classifiers there's a
small robot classifier and it's
computationally hard to learn any robust
classifier and and if you can construct
such a task cryptography I don't have
time to get into it but what I'm saying
is understanding these problems well
actually isn't also relevant to other
issues than just computing on encrypted
data it's sort of an interesting things
that could be related to robust - robust
classification and you can interpret
this in many ways one possibility is
learning parody with noise is actually
not hard I mean you don't because maybe
it's impossible to find a task for which
these three properties are true and just
one other thing is also related to
delegation so you know proving
proving that the computations done in
the cloud and the cloud wants to prove
to you that it was done correctly and he
wants to prove it with 16 proofs then
also under learning with errors there
are these very efficient proofs
computation so learning with errors
seems which is related to lattice crypto
is extremely useful piece of mathematics
to learn and that's it so I was gonna
write down all about NIST that they've
start planning for post quantum
cryptography and that is intimately tied
with understanding not a spec script
ography and there's lots of goals for
this semester one of them is going to be
interact with I think the Kwantung
program which are Miller I think is next
and I think the time is really great for
this because we we can do amazing things
but we have to make absolutely sure that
we've explored how robust this is for
quantum algorithms and for algorithms in
general and it would be good also to
work with mathematicians to understand
and distribute what kind of lattices
have structure in them and are still
instances safe because the more
structure we have more efficient these
systems are but then you're not using a
general assumption lots and lots of
great bones so I know that you're
getting very impatient and therefore I
shall stop
[Applause]